you give them an inch they take a mile
and i would say that the perfect example
of that is that cold open
that we just showed you of joe biden in
1998 yes you up in the back
do you agree with abortion do i agree
with abortion i agree my view is that
government
should not
make the judgment therefore i have voted
for 15 years consistently
against limiting the right of a woman to
make a decision with her doctor whether
or not she should have an abortion and
on the other side i have also voted
against direct government funding of
abortion if you say government should
stay out
government should stay out
in my view yes joe biden in 1998
sounding somewhat measured understanding
his own personal beliefs versus
government and all of those things
versus joe biden of today where he
basically is saying it is a fundamental
right they've taken away fundamental
rights they're coming after women and
all of this hysteria remember again the
only argument for voting for joe biden
as president was that he was the
firewall he was going to stop evil
fascist donald trump and he was the
firewall against crazy wokism and
ironically he's the one who has ushered
it in but the hysteria of course is not
just about the the politicians it also
is all of their friends in the media and
watch out people i'm about to show you a
clip
from the view
don't we uh separation yes
and have thomas jefferson there and
alexander hamilton hello yeah uh do we
still have the separation of church and
state here is in the constitution yeah
it's
the first amendment guarantee and we
don't seem to have that anymore
we're in a hypocrisy right now
okay the level of stupidity there is so
off the charts first off sunny hostin
this has nothing to do with the first
amendment you can say whatever you want
they can get up there and say that we
live in a theocracy okay it's not true
but they can say it uh also uh she's
talking about the separation of church
and state there was no religious
argument made in any of the supreme
court justice's paperwork on this there
was no nothing that had to do with
religion it was explicitly what is in
the constitution which is basically a
secular document uh the founders were
believers all in their own way and they
went back and forth in that and they
talked about a moral people and they
talked about the separation of church
and state obviously
no one is being dictated to live a
certain way right nobody is being
told oh you must believe in christ you
must be a christian and must do this or
that all this is is a
give back
it's a give back people like the the
buyback when they do gun buybacks this
is a give back of the power to the
states so this is a decentralization of
power what this is unearthing within the
progressives what it's showing all of us
is that they just want one power over us
they want one ring to rule us all
basically and that's what they're upset
about so here you have joy behar talking
about the separation of church and state
while she's basically spitting all over
the separation of powers the idea that
we do have a judiciary that decides
what's legal and a legislative branch
that writes the laws and an executive
branch that executes those laws right
that is what is a key
facet of the constitution of the rule of
law that we have here by the way the
definition of a theocracy since uh joy
behar brought that up a system of
government in which priests rule in the
name of god or a god
does that sound like what's happened
here they literally said hey states can
you figure out what's going on with
abortion you make your decisions and you
know hopefully the people in your states
will vote a certain way and then if you
want no abortions or eight-month
abortions or 12-week abortions or
whatever go ahead and do that does this
sound like the priests are doing
something in the name of god is that
what this really sounds like it's
endless
it's endless hysterical uh
hysterical lunacy i mean it's the only
way to put it but the new meme out there
also is that what they're coming for
next now that they've done this now that
they've given the rights
of abortion to the states and of course
you're allowed to leave the state and
get an abortion still but now that
they've done that they're coming for
interracial marriage black people will
not marry white people and of course
they're coming for gay marriage too
here's whoopi goldberg
i want people to have the lives they
want but i don't want to force anybody i
don't want anybody coming in my house
telling me how to raise my daughter and
what she needs because they don't know
these and i and i appreciate everybody's
religion but i do not subscribe to your
religion i don't ask you to subscribe to
mine and you do not have the right based
on your religious beliefs
to tell me because what's next as
clarence thomas is signaling they would
like to get rid of contraception do you
understand sir no because you don't have
to use it but that's crazy they don't
have to use it
now contraception's on the menu gay
marriage is not a whole probably going
to be because we weren't affirmative we
were not in the constitution either we
were not even people nothing is present
way more well you better hope that they
don't come for you clarence and say you
should not be married to your wife who
happens to be white
because they will move that and you
better hope that nobody says you know
well you're not in the constitution
you're back to being a quarter of the
15th that's not going to work either
we'll be right there all right sorry
[Applause]
man when i tell you that these people
need fear and endless hysteria to keep
people watching it's like has there ever
been a better example of that has there
ever been a better example of that do
you think that the supreme court is
coming for interracial marriage you know
the the founding documents which i
believe are the the best man-made
documents ever to free people to free
and imperfect people from ourselves from
our history and all of those things
which has led to 250 plus years of this
incredible evolution of freedom and more
and more equality for more people along
the way do i think that the supreme
court is suddenly going to say black
people cannot marry white people that's
what we're going to do you better watch
out clarence thomas and also
no matter how many videos you see of
these people the hypocrisy of this idea
that suddenly they want autonomy over
their lives and nobody over their bodies
and nobody's allowed to tell them what
they should do with their bodies the
same
people those are the same harping crazy
women who are demanding that other
people wear masks that other people get
vaccinated that we fire other people for
their own medical decisions and much
more which had certainly much more to do
with their own personal decisions you
were forced in no one's forcing anyone
to get an abortion you were forcing
people to be injected with something
whether you knew it worked or not and if
they didn't want to get injected the way
you wanted them to get injected with
they were potentially losing their job
that's what you freaks wanted just a
couple months ago and this is why if you
have no principles if your only
principle is power that you can exercise
over people you will end up seeming like
a crazy person much like whoopi goldberg
and joy behar and sonny hostin and anna
navarro and whoever else is sitting at
that table